climate change wackos just won't stop
this week the Looney Tunes shut down
traffic on a busy road during morning
Rush Hour the spokesperson the
spokeswoman of that protest actually
admits that activists want to make your
life hell and she's comparing her
actions to the Civil Rights Movement
we consciously are disrupting people's
lives today in hopes that we can
mitigate
more serious destruction down the road
the suffragettes the Civil Rights
Movement
um they were not well liked during their
time
now with hindsight we see that their
actions were moral and Justified
perfect it's absolutely perfect judge
the heroes of their own play
well you know first of all I don't know
what they expect to get out of this
destruction that is out of this disorder
we've talked about this many times
before but you know when she talked
about uh as a climate activist she
talked about you know they're not unlike
to suffragettes it's like a civil rights
movement we're not the first people to
do things that are really out of line so
I looked up uh what the women's
suffragettes did and what they did was
they lobbied now that's pretty violent
they petitioned uh they did parades and
they did pageants and they did plays
where they would at literally act out
what it's like to have equal rights and
whenever they picketed they did it
around the White House and I guess that
caused some problems around the White
House she's delusional if she thinks
that she's in line with the you know
with the Civil Rights and suffragettes
of this country so Jessica to the
judge's point if you continuously
um fall back on
threats shouting vandalism or violence
doesn't it reflect that you're part of a
movement that's actually pretty pretty
cultish and totally divorced from
reality and reason
I think that movements that are trying
to affect real change you could accuse
any of them of being cultish about it
the people are that dedicated to it
because they think it's that important
now the odds of this actually working
out are basically zero people just get
annoyed if you're in other countries
like we had that video in Italy where
people got out of their cars and picked
protesters up off the road and moved
them out of their way so they could get
on with their day and I happen to think
that the climate crisis is real and that
it's important to be addressing but
when you use terms like it's a civil
rights movement or you talk about the
suffragettes everybody who knows
anything about this their eyes glaze out
right roll your eyes glaze over because
I was thinking oh civil rights Heroes
I'm thinking about this woman also Rosa
Parks Ruby Bridges and John Lewis like
those conversations are happening in
people's homes absolutely not and it
detracts from the cause but I think Greg
I choose cult specifically as a word
because this seems to be despite its
invocations of science this is a
faith-based movement that requires total
dedication also the thing is the line if
you think something's really important
that's part of being an occult you will
justify anything like Hunter Biden well
no including like mass shootings like
somebody shoots up a church it's because
they have a greater idea that's usually
racist or whatnot so that the idea that
because of we don't care what the person
thinks this movement wants you to lose
their cool because they know how to play
the media right they want the attention
we provide it so the longer the the more
we play their stuff the better it is for
him but I have a question for you Mr
Sports guy why is it perfectly okay even
encouraged to brutally tackle and body
slam a spectator when they run onto a
field and disrupt a professional game
right if so if you can do that why this
is way worse there are ambulances trying
to get somewhere there are people trying
to get to work there needs to be an
exemption for people in cars to get out
grab these idiots and hurl them into the
bushes and if need be hold them down
take off their pants throw them into the
lake so they can't go anywhere and then
get back in your car because if we can
do that in a baseball game we could do
that there you maybe not have to take
off the pass that's just that was just
for fun that was just for fun but if you
want you know the thing is she was
talking about like in the future
environmentalists are never right look
at the look at Finland Greenpeace right
now well no longer protest nuclear power
this is a big deal because for 40 years
that's all Greenpeace did and they've
realized that that 40 Years of trying to
destroy nuclear power
may have led us to more climate change
because we stuck to fossil fuels War
because what is war about if not trying
to find cheaper energy and that means
whether it's batteries or gas we go into
other countries and we kill people over
energy energy is the only thing we live
for nuclear power is clean and it's safe
and Greenpeace fodder for four years now
they're realizing it's a mistake
I'm going to put the question to you
Jillian why can't we body slam and
Tackle targets that disrupt the commute
and leave out the part about the pants I
think that the solution to destruction
is more destruction same with violence
violence never should get more violence
it doesn't help anybody but I have to
say I understand the sentiment of and
this is somebody who's never protested
in my life but I understand the
sentiment of you see a system around you
or something that's going on that people
aren't aware of and it is we are aware
we hear about it every day what we hear
about it every day the climate every day
we don't know I'm not talking about
climate I'm just talking in general like
for example I feel this way about the
mistreatment of animals in factory farms
I feel like so
outrage sometimes that like I want to
scream I could I would if it would
accomplish anything but I realize it
won't so I understand the feeling of
like sometimes you need to like you want
to jolt people awake because these
horrible things are happening nobody
cares you know that she's also
rationalizing matter right I realize
that going and sitting in traffic on you
know Sixth Avenue is not going to help
this you know this question you've
presented me is a real stumper yeah just
don't understand why can't you like you
said if I can tackle the guy at the 50.
why can't I tackle the guy on the
highway exactly all right straight ahead
hey Sean Hannity here hey click here to
subscribe to Fox News YouTube page and
catch our hottest interviews and most
compelling analysis you will not get it
anywhere else